what kinda explorers have searched for  it centuries the golden city it's a  technological marvel I love watching  films on IMAX my favorite way to watch  movies we made some very specific  choices and where we got almost an hour  of footage that doesn't that expanded  view it's gonna be amazing and IMAX  because it's so overwhelming sometimes  the university as it is and when you  amplify that with a larger screen more  speakers you're gonna be treated like  this cornucopia of sensational imagery  and sounds that's what it's about that's  what you want to see it I mean is that's  where you want to go and see I wanna see  you there what happens now determines  what happens to the rest of the world  [Music]  [Music]